[Music]
uh so time then for the press preview a
first look at what is on sunday's front
pages tonight we'll see what's making
the headlines for the journalists and
author christina patterson also the
director of communications at the
institute of economic affairs annabelle
denham a very good evening to both of
you we'll chat in a moment but let's
have a look at those front pages for you
first of all we'll go through them
starting with the observer reporting
that conservative mps will be ready to
force boris johnson out within weeks if
he tries to dodge responsibility for
rule-breaking parties at number 10.
well the telegraph goes with the prime
minister's wife carrie photographed
breaking covid social distancing rules
days after the public was warned it was
critical to follow the guidance
all covered restrictions in england will
end in 10 days according to the sunday
express express the mirror goes with
prince andrews lawyers wanting to
question virginia duffrey's psychologist
to find out whether she's suffering
false memories of meeting him the duke
of york denies the claims against him
and the star leads with taxes on
single-use plastics such as cutlery
and balloons
and i'm joined by christina and
annabelle great to see you both this
saturday evening let's get stuck in then
christina starting with the observer
there is certainly a sense isn't there
that uh the public are furious about
what has been going on in recent days
and now uh the observer is reporting
that the tories will oust the prime
minister if he tries to dodge party gate
blame following the uh the the reports
findings from sue gray
yes well i i must say it's almost funny
that there are these constant ifs uh you
know that i think the times front page
today said last chance saloon and it's
if he's found to be evading
responsibility he's done nothing but
evade responsibility since these stories
first broke he's consistently lied about
them he claimed to not know there were
any parties he claimed to be really
really shocked when the allegra stratton
video emerged and and she is actually
the only person who has resigned in his
whole sorry business and she didn't even
go to any of the parties he claimed that
he was as horrified as the rest of the
nation and then drip drip drip the
parties come out i mean it's just
absolute non-stop party time at downing
street and he very clearly was and said
he was at that party in the garden with
trestle tail chest and tables of sausage
rolls and so on so i really don't know
what tory mps are waiting for clearly
well i think what they're waiting for is
to get a spine and to get a moral
compass because their constituents are
able to express what those tory mps
clearly aren't feeling which is
absolute horror that we have running our
country a prime minister who is not only
a pathological liar which we knew before
but that he set rules the most
restrictive movements
limitations on people's movement in
peace time
so that people literally watched family
dying on ipads you know they watched
their loved ones dying on ipads they
couldn't even hold their hands when they
died and meanwhile it was part of your
go-go with dj's drink uh suitcases of
booze
fridges constant trips out to the tesco
at westminster so really i think i think
tory mps could just get a spot
i'm just going to break in because we
are short of time sadly this evening and
i want to speak to annabelle in a moment
but the prime minister has apologized to
the public in the commons downing street
apologized to the queen he's called for
an inquiry shouldn't we just wait to
hear what that inquiry says we'll know
probably by the end of the week
well he didn't apologize did he he
absolutely didn't apologize he he said
he basically said no rules were broken
it was a work do which was certainly a
category which didn't appear anywhere
well and actually it was very clear that
there's no such thing as [ __ ] do you
couldn't have a work party nobody in the
country was allowed a work party so he
didn't apologize number one and sure we
can all wait for the sue gray report but
since we know he was at the party that
was illegal i can't really see what
she's going to say but fine i mean
clearly tori and peace have no idea what
to do they don't have a replacement
lined up um they don't know how to
handle this whole thing and so
everybody's saying we'll wait for the
report and and anyway sue gray's not
going to pass judgment she she's her her
remit is to lay out the fact yeah
rather than dish out sanctions yeah okay
let's move on to the sunday telegraph
annabelle carrie johnson broke covered
rules apparently now you've you've read
this story what what do you make of it
it happened in september 2020 i think
um there were guidelines weren't they
rather than strict rules am i right and
saying
well there were guidelines but i think
most people
followed those guidelines adhered to
those guidelines pretty strictly and
will be i mean you know i'm looking at
this these headlines with my head with
my head my hands one can only imagine
the depth of despair that the comms
machine at number 10 have plunged to i
think the public are absolutely furious
at all of this and seeing images of the
prime minister's wife with her arms
around a friend
at a time when that guidance was in
place is certainly not going to
help matters but
she's not she's not an election she's
not elected
yes and she isn't it's
the one rule for them and one rule for
the rest of us might apply but she
wasn't the ones setting those rules so
the hypocrisy is not quite so
galling uh for members of the public i
don't imagine but i do think a problem
that we're going to quickly run into
here is that there are so many breaches
by so many people in positions of
privilege that we might soon lose sight
of those that actually require further
actions some conservatives with slamming
kierstarma who seemed at least from the
footage i saw to be having a quiet beer
with a few colleagues you know how much
mud is going to be slung and you know
should we really be focusing on the most
egregious examples to ensure that the
public doesn't become desensitized to
you know what appears to be the really
unconscionable behaviors yeah um you
make a good point and let's move on to
the front of sunday express christina
prime minister ditches all rules but
will it save him we're hearing that
maybe in 10 days all rules all covered
restrictions will be lifted i mean that
will be a huge relief to the country
well you know what i don't think it will
i think that i think it's tory mps who
get really upset about regulations
during a pandemic which are pretty light
touch actually all the only thing that's
that's sort of left is for the advice of
people to work from home if they can and
to wear masks in crowded spaces it's not
particularly onerous i mean i do think
generally speaking it's better for
people to be an office if they can be
but you know during a pandemic is not
really the prime time so i i think this
is really shocking the fact that boris
johnson is changing safety regulations
during a pandemic to save his skin well
we don't know that christina do we he's
he'll be he'll be saying he's following
the science
well he he doesn't really follow signs
but the headline literally says it's to
save him um you know it may be for other
reasons and if it's for other reasons
fine you know these are the judgments he
has to make but if it is to placate
himself with tory mps and we know he's
going all out with operation big dog the
most horrifically named uh salvation
operation ever and he is determined to
save his own skin according to all the
sources and it looks as if this is part
of that process i heard actually from a
senior tory mp this evening of um
another thing to do with the bbc license
fee which may well have um which you
know may well be quite fierce it also in
order to placate tory mps so um you know
it's
i think this is i think this is awful
like this is not how policy should you
make annabelle we've only got 30 seconds
um
where do you see this story in terms of
the lifting of restrictions
sure i'm afraid i share christina's
cynicism let's not forget that boris
johnson deployed the dead cat dead cat
strategy back in december to distract
from the footage of allegra stratton
laughing about parties in number 10. now
he's lifting plan b restrictions which
would have been loathed in particular by
conservative backbenchers because they
are coming under fire from their
constituents from their local
associations uh feeling immense pressure
worrying that they're not going to be
re-elected in the next general uh
election but i don't think that we
should
underestimate the impact of plan b
restrictions and the fact that they
could have cost us about four billion
pounds a month they might represent
small changes in individual behavior but
those uh multiple small changes in
individual behavior can have quite an
impact on the economy so i certainly
welcome them a time when and on a day
when uh omicron cases have uh hit their
lowest in a month yeah okay sorry to
have to rush you both along we'll speak
again in a moment coming up after the
break and look at the tsunami in tonga
pictured here on the front of the
observers
[Music]
welcome back part two of the press
preview christina and annabelle still
with me annabelle uh why don't we have a
look at the sunday mirror um andrew
prince andrew um trying to potentially
quiz uh virginia dufrese psychologist
yes uh the mirror has
got
a very unflattering splash talking about
andrew's memory and
and how stark that contrast is uh his
inability to remember certain uh facts
or
alleged facts from the past alleged
incidents in the past compared with
virginia dufrey's memory which his
lawyers are now calling into question of
course he's innocent until proven guilty
but front pages like this do give a good
indication of andrew's standing in the
court of public opinion i think it's
very difficult to see how his reputation
will recover from what has been
a very troublesome very difficult week
uh for the prince of course earlier this
week the queen clearly put monarchy
before motherhood by bringing down the
guillotine on andrew's royal
career in a 19-minute meeting the royal
family quite obviously distancing
themselves from this unfolding disaster
and i think
in the coming weeks if the decision is
made not to settle this case as swiftly
and quietly as possible then we are
going to see more headlines like there's
more front page splashes like this
in the coming weeks and months yeah
christina this story really isn't going
away it's been quite a week hasn't it
for prince andrew
yes it's been quite a week for prince
andrew i i it looks to me as if well i
mean i'm i'm pleased that this is going
to court because um i reviewed last year
julie k brown's book about brian epstein
for the sunday times and she she's
essentially the person who
got him into prison and who is really
responsible for getting virginia
for getting gailan maxwell prosecuted
because people had refused to touch the
case for years and years and years and
he had um an extremely light sentence
for a minor relatively minor crime um
and it was her research that got you
know got the case kind of uncovered in
this way and what
i have read about the prince andrew case
does not sound good at all and obviously
he will fight this but there has been
this photo around for years to claim he
doesn't remember it and then accuse her
of false memory syndrome seems just
crazy to me and i do feel very sorry for
the queen but justice is justice and if
he has
essentially raped virginia jeffrey
because um she was underage at the time
then uh then you know he should pay the
price for that and losing his reputation
is the least of it frankly if you if you
commit a crime you shouldn't just lose
your reputation you should actually be
prosecuted and face more than that but
we'll see what happens but i think there
is absolutely no choice then what the
queen has done and of course uh yeah we
should just say once again he does uh
strenuously as you did strenuously deny
all those allegations just very quickly
annabelle uh literally in the last 10
seconds this remarkable picture of the
eruption in tonga
yes the blast that could be seen uh from
space uh you know obviously at the
moment we know uh very little the u.s
and japan are advising people on the
pacific coastlines to get away from the
shore as a precaution against tsunami
waves japan has warned of waves as high
as three meters um
what us warned of strong currents and
waves coastal flooding so i think that
you know there's going to be more to
come and we just have to hope that
the effects of the tsunami are not too
catastrophic